>>> IN OUR NATIONAL LEADS TY RE
HOLDING T CLDIVA
HOLDING PRT CLAUDINE
YOU MIGHT RECALL DR. GAY ALONG
SIDENTS OF.
GENERALLY SES ONTH
TH FAILED TO E
THAT KATHE GENOCIDE OF
JEWS O THEDE ON US AND TT ANHE
PROGRESSIVE POLICIES HAVE MADE
SCUES AB
OF THE PROVIDENCE
ALLEGATIONS THERIS MATTE OR NOT.
REVEALEINADEQUATE
GU
AY ANY N
VIOLATIO
IN ACADEMIC WRITING IT IS
SOMEONE ELSE WHOCRITANY IDEA ORG
PAPER,ENTE AND HARVARD'S OLEGATY
THIS.  DOUBLE.S MATT EGAN IS FOO
MAATS DR. GAACCUSED OF HERE.
>> CLAUDINE GAY'S CAREER
UNDER A MI
NOW SHE'S FACING ACCUSATIONSPLA.
GAD CORRON
PAPERS THAT WROTE IN001
R EXAMPLES OF IA
THURRED IN THEN
SHE WAS  PH.SH ONE PARAGRAPH AL
ER HT CITATI
ANNS
ILL QURY
AC UP TO ANDD  WITHDRAW  LLEGE.
STANCEES
PROPERLTE
IN A 1993 ESSAY.
WERE FIREP
ACON'SYS SOME OF THE
POHARVAR A IT AWARE OAGIARISM
ALLEGATIONE
A
W AN
UT NN OFD
HOWEVER, IT'S NOT CLEAR WHR  RE
DESEHARVARD ED PLA
1990s.
SC COMMENT.
IN A PREVIOUS STATEMENT GAY
MY SCHOLARSHIP VE TO ENSURE MYI
HEC
ST
WEHOA
ALL
AND ONE OF THOSETSE
CR BY THE HARVARD
HILIPLCHARGES AND  W
GAY TOQUAGIARISM EXPERTS THAT C
SPOKE TO STR I
COMPX
ONANY BU
CALLED FOR HER TO BEED ANDIT'S Q
RER MRI
ITIC ABOUTD'REVIEWE SM
>> ONE IS THE RD PULLED OFF
THIS INDEPENDENT REVIEW.
>>NG ARISM REVIEWS
CAN ROM TWO MONTHS TO TWO ARAN O
HS.
PRESIDENT OF THE UE SHOULD ESI
Y
ACTIVISTS WHO ARE  NCERNED ABOUC
ACTIVISTHODS,
PRESIDENTS OF
LIST P HER JAKE,
MBER WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
INERENT CATEGORIES.
ATTRIBUTION AND ANOTHER IS
STEALING SOMEONE ELSE'S IDEAS
D HICEE ALL IN THECAMP.
IDEA THE B TONBU
FUTUS  HARVARD BE
PUS TYME OSEINVITING A LAWSUIT
SOMETHING THT
GET AWAY WIT TCO